[Music]
across the world protesters have taken
to the streets after the killing of
George Floyd at the hands of four police
officers in Minneapolis they're not only
calling for justice but for the reform
of the American police system altogether
most of the protests have been peaceful
but others have led to violent clashes
and even more police brutality we are
seeing a level of intensity and fever
cross the country that is signaling to
elected leaders that something needs to
be done differently in Philadelphia
police officers in riot gear pepper
sprayed protesters who appeared trapped
between a freeway and a fence
[Music]
but just across the Delaware River in
Camden New Jersey a very different scene
police officers in Camden New Jersey are
being praised tonight for joining the
protesters there this weekend
this was not a happy accident and it did
not happen overnight the reason why Kim
is not boiling over this isn't because
we went out marched with them on one day
it's because we've been with them every
day for the last seven years building
goodwill and Trust is something that
takes a long time and so when a moment
comes like this the police chief has the
credibility to walk with demonstrators
so how did Camden get to this point and
is its reputation as a shining example
of police reform truly deserved
[Music]
kantha New Jersey hasn't always been a
bastion of police reform just under a
decade ago the majority black and
Hispanic city was one of the poorest in
America and it still is today the
biggest challenge that residents face is
the impact that being in impoverished
City brings
just the daily struggle of making enough
money to pay bills and then on top of
that violence is part of the experience
of living in Camden I lost two people
back-to-back of a murder
I was shot myself in 2006 as an innocent
bystander any single person we talked to
in the city knows someone who's either
been shot or murdered last summer we had
three people shot two blocks that way we
had a person shot one block that way
just last week at this time of the day
we had a person shot right in front of
this store there was a moral imperative
to do something different you know to be
quite frank with you the organization
was one that any community member on the
street would probably describe as
apathetic lethargic and corrupt before
the reforms Camden agreed to pay 3.5
million dollars in damages to 88 people
whose convictions were overturned
because of rampant corruption within the
police department typical of communities
of color nationwide excessive force was
high and trust of law enforcement was
low so in 2013 after spikes in murder
year after year the City Police
Department was dissolved entirely and
placed under control of the county we've
created a countywide force that is
putting more police officers on the
streets of Camden and putting more
resources at their disposal the
governing bodies of the city the county
and in the state of New Jersey all fell
in a line with the idea that something
radical had to happen something
different was was the mandate
that mandate was a complete overhaul
fundamentally changing how the
department was run all the officers were
fired and then most rehired after taking
a pay cut in just under two years the
number of officers nearly doubled from
250 to 400 and in 2019 it implemented
one of the strongest use of force
policies in the country much of
traditional police training over the
years was you exert command and control
you do so swiftly and forcefully and
that will resolve situations quickly and
more safely but yet the evidence never
really bear doubt on that and what we
have learned over time is that if you
apply certain strategies and tactics you
can have a safer resolution of these
traditional violent offense that have
better ending results for the subject
that you're dealing with and the officer
as well one of the changes that we
advocate for here at the policing
project is to encourage departments that
give their officers more guidance
require de-escalation ban chokeholds and
strangleholds make sure that deadly
force is only used as a last resort it's
driving home the belief that just
because we can use force does not mean
we should use force and here are a menu
of options that you can employ and this
is what we did in Camden you're actually
required to run through that menu before
you do use force
that change did not come easily even
with bipartisan support from the
Governing Board of the city county and
state in new jersey police viewed it as
union-busting my first stop doesn't
pleased you I had a label organization
that would probably be more categorized
as defense attorneys for cops they
fought me on every single issue you know
if I said the sky was blue they would
say it was black
anything that was trying to be done in
progressive manner they exhausted
significant amount of resources to
maintain status demolishing one
department is switching to new was an
extreme reaction to an extreme problem
good officers lost their jobs lost their
income because of the sloppy way the
transition happen now it was sloppy but
is also unprecedented nothing like that
had ever happened in the United States
let alone New Jersey and that may be the
grand sacrifice that's made when you're
trying to eliminate a department that
has many issues by the police
departments account since 2012 reports
of excessive force complaints have
dropped by 95% and homicides which reach
67 in 2012 have dropped almost every
year since used to be you call them
today become the mom now 20 minutes
today the department is much better the
officers have a faster response time
they have body cameras you can see the
impact of the training they had on both
de-escalation and implicit bias we
essentially were able to drop murders by
more than 70% and cut violent crime in
half by empowering the people of the
community and given them the ability to
reclaim their neighborhoods rather than
us just militarizing city streets and
further polarizing and revitalizing many
people within the community when you
match courage with compassion with care
and understanding of the community like
we've seen here in Camden some really
outstanding things can begin to happen I
think Canada is doing a great job but
the only people who could really tell
you that are the residents of Camden and
I think if they are walking with the
chief and they feel like they're being
heard then then we know it's working
however for residents and activists in
Camden some question how much real
progress has been made especially since
Scott Thompson's retirement in 2019 the
reason why we are organizing today is to
show that Camden has been praised as the
model for police form across the country
and today we want to make sure that
everyone knows that Camden's not the
symbol that should be spread across the
country for law enforcement
it stands for over policing it stands
for a police force that doesn't
represent the city that it serves our
police force like Morristown
[Music]
I'm not here to say how terrible the
police are doing we're saying that if
President Obama comes here in 2015 and
tells you you're the symbol of police
reform across the country then let's
hold you to a higher standard it's not
here just for symbolism we want to see
those real change and because the Canada
residents know the real story behind a
can of Police Department
despite Camden having one of the
strictest use of force policies in the
country there have still been 3183
examples of force used by officers from
2012 to 2016 a statement from the Camden
Police Department says quote every use
of force incident is reviewed through
body worn camera footage and if
something was done incorrectly the
officer is sent to remedial training in
addition there have been multiple
reports of officers exerting unnecessary
force including a man being punched by
an officer multiple times in the face
during an arrest that officer was fired
the next day within 24 hours
our entire senior command staff was
ordered to go into role Falls
played that video and challenged the
room full of officers
does anyone here support or think what
they're seeing here is lawful or
consistent with our policies and that if
you were to engage in this type of
behavior you're an outlier and you don't
have our support and we don't you use
one of us so while there was swift
action brought against the offending
officers caught on tape critics say
there are many officers who have used
force and not been held accountable
the people who police the police in
America are the police with internal
investigations conducted by other
officers in addition Camden does not
have a civilian review board where
citizens investigate complaints by the
public concerning misconduct by police
officers and there are calls that it
needs one the number one thing that
needs to change is for policing and
police policymaking to become more
democratic I think that the communities
that bear the brunt of policing need to
have a bigger voice and what that
actually looks like
so when it comes to the democratization
of the police it also extends to the
democratization of police
responsibilities when Scott Thompson was
the chief with the candan police he said
one line over and over again nothing
stops a bowl like a job which is a job
that isn't controlled by the police even
with the training and body cams and all
those good things that our department
now has are not enough to really do what
should be our ultimate goal which is to
make sure that families are able to make
enough money to pay their bills to
support their children send them the
good quality schools when chief Thompson
says that I think stops a bullet like a
job I don't think that he thinks it's
the police's job to make sure everyone's
employed I think he thinks it's
government's job to think holistically
about the problem so if you could tell
any major Police Department that we're
actually going to invest in social
services so that homelessness and hope
yo addiction are taken off your plate
and put onto someone else's maybe they'd
be laying a shift funding a little bit
ultimately candid story is about
changing the rules of engagement for
police officers and the numbers suggest
those changes have made policing here
more humane and effective than seven
years ago but those reforms are just the
beginning of what community organizers
say is needed this is a start of
something new this is a start of a
movement in Camden to hold the police
force accountable to hold community
leaders accountable for the change that
the people of Camden really want police
around America needs to be well versed
in the history of social injustice
around the country they need to be aware
of their internal biases and until that
happens I don't see the police around a
nation making a true change
you